اليكم خبر صار
فينا يتعلق بحريه الصحافه هذا صحفي
الجزيره هشام عبد العزيز كان معتقل بدون
محاكمه في مصر الخبر السار هو انه اطلق
سراحه قبل ايام
ولكن لدي خبر سيء كذلك ربيع محمد عبد
الواحد الشيخ صحفي اخر للجزيره لا يزال
معتقل في مصر بدون محاكمه خبر سيء اخر هذا
بهاء الدين ابراهيم نعمه الله صحفي
للجزيره لا يزال هو ايضا معتقل بدون
محاكمه في مصر ثم هناك طبعا مراسله
الجزيره
شيرين ابو عقله التي مضى على مقتلها
برصاصه اسرائيليه عام
ولا تزال العداله لم تتحقق في مقتلهم حريه
التعبير تعكس حاله مجتمعنا واذا تراجعت
فكافه الحقوق التي ترافقها تتراجى لقد كنا
واضحين ومتصقين بشان ادانه القتل الماساوي
لشيرين منذ البدايه وعندما خرج التقرير
الامريكي وكذلك التقرير الاسرائيلي للعلن
الصيف الماضي تحدثنا باستمرار عن الحاجه
والدعوه للمساءله في هذه القضيه وما زلنا
نفعل ذلك
نقوم بعملنا ونحب القيام به والجميع
يعلمون ان شيرين احبت العمل الصحفي وقول
الحقيقه حول ما يحدث للشعب الفلسطيني سواء
في القدس او في الضفه الغربيه ايضا حيث
تعيش جدتي
قد كانت شيرين دوما في واجهه الاحداث تصف
وتقول الحقيقه كي توصل الى العالم برمته
صوره انسانيه للفلسطينيين واحاول انا
القيام بشيء نفسه في الكون
كنا نعرف حقيقتها منذ وكانت معروفه لدينا
جميعا وكانت فخوره بعملها واتمنى لو كانت
الولايات المتحده ايضا فخوره بعمل شيرين
بحيث تسعى لتحقيق العداله في قضيه مقتلها
فلم يكن الامر كذلك في حال شديد وانا اشعر
بخيبه الامل وعاضبه على حكومتنا التي غضت
النظر عما جرت اذ اعتقد ان الامريكيين
اليوم يرون نتيجه المساعدات الهائله التي
تقدمها الولايات المتحده دون قيود مبلغ
اربعه مليارات دولار تقريبا سنويا تقدم
لدوله تعتبرها ثلاث منظمات لحقوق الانسان
دوله فصل عنصري ما حدث في قضيه شيرين هو
انهم ياملون ان ننسى ولكننا لم ننسى ونعرف
ان شيرين لم تكن اخر مواطن امريكي يقتله
الاسرائيليون
اعتقد انه امر مشين للغايه ان يحدث ما حدث
لصحفيه مثل شيرين لقد كانت مميزه بشكل خاص
بسبب معرفتها والتزامها وبسبب النموذج
الذي قدمته للصحفيه ليس في المنطقه فحسب
بل حول العالم يجب ان لا يمر قتل هادون
العداله الملائمه في الحقيقه لقد دعوت
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
الذي كما تعلمون يعمل الان على قضايا قتل
الصحفيين في اوكرانيا وقلت له لا تنسى
فلسطين ولا تنسى شيرين